معنا من الامم المتحده في نيويورك فرحان
حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده اهلا بك سيد فرحان ونبدا بهذه
الاتهامات الموجهه من يعني الدفاع المدنيه
السوريه والذي يقول انكم تقومون بتسييس
هذه المساعدات بالاضافه لانكم وجهتم
تهديدات للمنظمات الانسانيه السوريه
تطالبها بدور المحدود هل
سمعتم او ورد عليكم اي معلومات من هذه
التهديدات
هذه الاتهامات حقيقه
زائفه تماما الامم المتحده في الحقيقه لها
موقف قوي ضد تسييس الاغاثه الاغاثه
بالنسبه الينا اولويه ان يصل الى كل من
يحتاجها ايا كان مكانهم وعلى اي طرف وجهه
من الحدود او اي جهه من القتال ينتبهون
اليها واضح ان هذا الزلزال تجاوز الحدود
الوطنيه
والحدود السياسيه وترك مئات الالاف من
الناس نازحين ويعانون من شتى انواع الحاجه
ونحن نريد ان نصل اليهم جميعا لهذا السبب
نحن ننشط في سوريا ونعمل من خلال ثلاثه
معابر حدوديه وايضا من خلال نقاط عبر
الحدود هذا ببساطه غرضها الن صر الى اكبر
عدد ممكن من الناس ايا كانوا طيب الواضح
جدا ان هناك احتقان ما في بين المنظمات
المحليه العامله في سوريا وبين الوكالات
التابعه للامم المتحده الم يكن بالامكان
تفادي هذا الاحتقان في ظل المولى الاولويه
الان هي لانقاذ كما قلت
نحن بالتاكيد ان ننوي ان نعمل بشكل جيد مع
كل المجموعات على الارض وقد فعلنا ذلك
طيله فتره الحرب وننوي ان نقوم به طيله
فتره اغاثه المنكوبين بالزلزال لكن في
خاتمه المطاف علينا ان نضمن ان
الطرف من هذه الاطراف يستخدم هذه الاغاثه
للحصول على ميزه سياسيه ومكسب سياسي على
حساب الطرف الاخر فليس من الانسانيه بمكان
ان نستغل معاناه الناس لتحقيق مكاسب
سياسيه ما نود ان نقوم به هو ان نضمن ان
القضيه هي قضيه ايصال المساعدات لكل من
يحتاجها عندما نتجاوز مرحله المعاناه
سنكون قد حققنا جميعا وسنعمل مع الجميع
لنضمن ان المساعدات تنقل الى الناس الذين
يحتاجونها طيب حجم الدمار والمعاناه خاصه
في الشمال السوري كبير جدا ويبدو انه
يحتاج الى نطاق عمل يتجاوز الايام
والاسابيع وصحح لي هنا ان كنت مخطئه
وبالتالي هل لديكم خطه مستقبليه تضع في
حسبانيا هذا الامر
من الاهميه بمكان ان يتعلم الجميع الدروس
مما حدث والنعصر على طرق
لاعاده
البناء وما يتم اعاده بناءه بدل المباني
التي تضررت ان تكون قادره على تحمل الهزات
في المستقبل في خاتمه المطاف كل من يبني
في تركيا في سوريا في هذه المناطق يجب ان
يعيا ان هذه مناطق
صدع
زلزاليه
والصفائحيه
تحركت في الماضي وعندما يبنون اي بناء يجب
ان ياخذوا كل ذلك فان الاعتبار نحن من
جهتنا نركز على الدعم الاضافي وعندما ياتي
الوقت المناسب ننتقل الى مرحله اعاده
الاعمار الدائمه احنا مستعدون لذلك السيد
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
لامم المتحده حدثنا من مقر الامم المتحده
في نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك